wenn enkel einer familie in einem
anderen land in israel geimpft werden
können und die großeltern hier auf die
impfung warten obwohl sie dringender
bräuchte
fakt ist da muss was schief gelaufen
sein
die transparenz wie genau muss noch
hergestellt werden denn erkennbar ist ja
dass entweder zu wenig bestellt wurde
deswegen hat man ja nachbestellt
offenkundig auch zu bürokratisch mann
hat offensichtlich auch beim thema
lieferketten nicht genau geprüft und
vorgesorgt denn jetzt steht ja so ein
bisschen der verdacht im raum wird alle
impfstoff der in europa produziert wird
sogar in europa dann auch verimpft oder
geht er woanders sind bei den einzelnen
partnern wie einem neuen impfstoff der
erzeuger in diskussion war bleiben auch
fragen ist der überhaupt geeignet für
ältere ja oder nein das muss jetzt
geklärt werden weil danach würde sich im
übrigen auch die im pfarrarchiv bzw die
im freien folge dann nochmal komplett
ändern
also das sind eine menge fragen und
eines ist etwas wo ich nach wie vor
nicht ganz verstehe
wir sind ein farmer land wir sind ein
industrie wie sie es muss doch gelingen
das aus einem einzigen werk in marburg
mehr getan werden kann um impfstoff zu
produzieren
also ich würde noch mal dringend raten
das ist ja eine echte notsituation beim
impfen geht es zum einen um leben aber
es geht auch um freiheit und
wirtschaftliche stärke wenn die usa in
großbritannien viele andere partner
länder der welt deutlich schneller aus
der situation herauskommen weil sie
geimpft sind übrigens die neue impfung
hilft die auch gegen das neue virus
möglicherweise also ist eine doppelte
doppelter wettlauf mit der zeit dann
müssten wir die bemühungen wirklich
darauf konzentrieren und nicht nur jeden
tag darüber reden sondern schneller und
effizienter handeln
sie haben gesagt man muss auch noch mal
schauen was deiner vergangenheit
passiert ist wenn wir das jetzt mal ganz
kurz tun und in den sommer zurück gehen
da gab es den gesundheitsminister der
versucht hat mit einzelnen europäischen
staaten gemeinsam einen verbund zu
gründen dann wurde es auf druck der
kanzlerin unter anderem an die eu
verwiesen dann hat die zypriotische
gesundheitskommissarin und vor von der
leyen das übernommen war es ein fehler
dass komplett an die eu kommission zu
geben und hätte der gesundheitsminister
hier früher deutlicher machen müssen wir
in deutschland müssen uns auch selbst
kümmern
ich glaube dass da jeder versucht in
deutschland die kanzeln auch jenen
sparen das ja unermüdlich jeden tag auch
im fernsehen und überall und kämpft ja
da an der front jeder versucht
sicherlich das ein beitrag zu erbringen
aber letztlich ist es wie im fußball das
ergebnis zählt etwas also ich bin auch
sehr gegen jede form von imf
nationalismus
er macht nur sorge dass andere länder
offenkundig schneller und effizienter
bestellt haben
wenn ich dann so höre aber das sind
alles nur informationen die man am rande
bekommt wenn ich dann höre dass
möglicherweise man auch ein wirklich
hervorragendes klassisches
traditionelles bieter und verfahren hat
in dem über preise geredet wird dann
stellt sich die frage ob man nicht hätte
mehr bestellen sondern und so einen
besseren höheren preis abschließen
müssen
denn wenn es am ende ja zu viel
impfstoff gegeben hätte dann hätte man
den auch weitergeben können der bedarf
bleibt ja übrigens auf dauer ist nicht
so dass der korona impfstoff dann nicht
mehr gebraucht wird und das ist dann ab
sommer vorbei ist und ich hoffe halt
einfach sehr dass die jetzt gemachten
sicheren versprechen dass mehr im stoff
kommt dass er schneller kommt dass bis
zum sommer alle geimpft sind die
versprechen würden ja abgegeben
die müssen auch eingehalten werden und
das wird schon noch sportlich und
ambitioniert und ich sage es noch einmal
ich mir tut es auch in der seele weh
wenn unglaublich viele menschen die
jetzt wirklich dran wären nicht geimpft
werden können aber hören in anderen
ländern der welt wird durch geimpft und
zwar rasch schnell ohne ende
da haben wir jetzt wirklich noch eine
menge zu tun man darf das wirklich nicht
unterschätzen
das impfen ist die langzeitstrategie und
ist die lösung auf diese pandemie
sie gibt uns freiheit zurück sie gibt
uns normalität und sie gibt uns am ende
auch wirtschaftliche stärke und
natürlich vor allen dingen den schutz
des lebens
sie sprechen immer wieder das deutsche
vaterland anhaben auch den biotech
standort dort den marburg noch mal
angesprochen wo mehr rauszuholen sein
müsste noch mal konkret nachgefragt wie
kriegen weil es dann hin also ist da in
marburg mehr rauszuholen oder muss
insgesamt aus unserem pharma land mehr
rauszuholen sein und vor allen dingen
wie wie kriegen wir das hin
müssen die zuständigen stellen sich noch
mal überlegen ich überlege mir immer
wenn so wenn so einer extremen
notsituation wie jetzt ist und ich
glaube das ist eine notsituation die
sprechen nicht umsonst von der größten
bewährungsprobe nicht nur unserer
generation sondern seit generationen
dann muss doch ein land in der lage sein
auch europa das ja auch viele andere
produktionsstätten hat den output zu
erhöhen umzustellen bei bestimmten
produktionen das kann man ja unternehmen
die dann da bereits stehen dafür
ersetzen und mitmachen und es muss
natürlich auch beschleunigt werden
das hatte szenario glaube ich sind die
ersten genehmigungen erteilt das ist gut
aber das kann ja nicht nur ein werk
gegen ein ehemaliges kann ja auch sein
dass vor bestehende produktionsabläufe
umgerüstet werden können
also ist die frage herr söder gar nicht
so naiv die ich immer wieder auf der
straße höre wenn man sagt wir haben doch
diese riesigen unternehmen hier wie
bayer zum beispiel und so weiter und so
fort warum produzieren die das ding
nicht einfach durch nach so vielen
monaten ist das naiv oder ginge das die
frage ist nicht naiv zunächst mal ist
keine frage verstehen sie das ist ja das
was auf der hand liegt und es hat ja
auch erste gespräche gute gespräche
glaube ich gegeben in berlin mit den
großen pharma unternehmen ein farmer
gipfel aber das ergebnis lässt wohl noch
auf sich warten ich kann nur noch mal
raten das liegt ja in der hand des
bundes dort noch druck zu machen und im
zweifelsfall diesen druck auch zu
erhöhen wir müssen uns genau überlegen
wie wir hat mir mit der mutation
außerhalb unseres landes umgehen wir
haben zum teil schon vor weihnachten
begonnen in bayern mit mehr test
pflichten bei reiserückkehrern wir
wurden damals ein bisschen kritisiert
deshalb jetzt im reinen rausgestellt der
bund hat gott sei dank für mich auch
richtig diese regelung übernommen
jetzt kommt hinzu dass wir zusätzliche
testflächen wie gehen beispielsweise bei
vogue risikogebieten wie tschechien und
das müssen wir sehr aufpassen was bei
mutations gebieten passiert wir müssen
sehr darauf achten dass ich durch diese
super mutations gebiete nicht eine
zusätzliches risiko ergibt das dann
durch den eintrag bei uns ergibt
deswegen glaube ich sollte man alle
maßnahmen überprüfen
es ist sowohl das thema grenzkontrollen
muss diskutiert werden
als auch bei der einreise sehr darauf zu
achten und auch dackel der grundsatz
oder super mutations gebilden sollte die
der reiseverkehr so reduziert werden
dass er nicht zum risiko wird alles
prüfen grenzkontrollen sagen sie auch
grenzschließungen in dem freistaat
bayern das grenzland ist da ein
grenzkontrollen werde jetzt mal das
sinnvoll zieht es klappt auch ganz gute
haben umfangreiche tests pflichten
gestern hat der tschechische premier
mich angerufen wir hatten ein
konstruktives gespräch auch da war so
der wunsch können wir nicht
möglicherweise die tests pflichten für
pendler abbauen
das geht leider nicht wir bieten ein
testangebot zusätzlich an
aber die tests müssen seien es geht
jetzt einfach um sicherheit und wir
müssen von den hohen zahlen weiter
runter kommen nur dann haben wir wieder
die chance auch mehr stabilität zu geben
und freiheit wenn sie nochmal das jahr
im rückblick sehen dann ist es zum
beispiel so dass die öffnungen im
frühjahr bei tänzen waren die zum teil
unter zehn waren und jetzt immer in
deutschland auch bei einer inzidenz über
100 das heißt das ist noch sehr
sportliche aufgabe die wir zu leisten
haben bei einer gleichzeitig um uns
herum doch noch sehr hohen
infektionsrate und das macht schon sorge
und da hilft es nichts wir müssen weiter
konsequent den weg gehen müssen sie am
ende hilft es nicht den bequemsten weg
zu gehen sondern infizieren bis
nordwesten
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren